dirk du bist oft er für die sendung
faszination erde expedition in die
zukunft auf der neumayer station 3 im
ewigen eis also quasi fast am südpol
wie ist die fast ehrlich gesagt wie ist
die lage am südpol wie sieht es aus
dauern wie geht's euch uns geht es prima
tatsächlich ist es auch für mich die
weiteste live schalte die ich je gemacht
habe ich glaube wir sind gerade 14.000
kilometer auseinander
wahnsinn wahnsinn also diese neumayer
station in bei der du bist die die sieht
so aus als wenn die auf stelzen steht
also die steht gar nicht auf dem eis
sondern sie steht auf stelzen oder wer
es wie ist das ja das sieht wirklich aus
wie ein ufo das sie am ewigen eis
gelandet ist untersteht tatsächlich auf
stelzen und nicht einfach nur auf
stelzen sondern auf hydraulischen
stelzen
das problem ist nämlich wir sind hier
auf dem ewigen eis also unter mir 200
meter unter mir ungefähr ist das meer
und darüber eine 200 meter dicke
eisschicht und wenn du auf diese
eisschicht eine antarktisstation baust
weil ja wärmer ist als das eis schmilzt
die sich langsam in den untergrund das
heißt auch verschwindet und genau das
ist auch mit der neumayer station 1 und
2 passiert dass der hinter mir ist
neumeier drei und damit die nicht auch
unter geht hat man die auf stelzen
gestellt und diese stelzen kann man dann
einmal im jahr hydraulisch ein bisschen
hoch fahren also jedes mal wenn die
station ein bisschen ein sind dann fährt
man nacheinander die hydraulischen
stelzen bisschen hoch und so bleibt das
ding hier tatsächlich über jahrzehnte
lang über der oberfläche eine ganz tolle
technik wie ist das leben in so einer
auf so einer hoch gehobenen hochgehoben
und stationen wie lebt sich da so also
ich bin manchmal wirklich froh dass das
hier eine deutsche forschungsstation ist
ich habe in meinem leben schon überall
auf der welt forschungsstation gesehen
aber das hier ist ab sofort meine
lieblings station denn da drin kann man
es wirklich aushalten
also das ding hat 5000 quadratmeter
fläche ungefähr die hälfte davon ist
sogar beheizt ist ja der dax ist nicht
ganz gründlich den dies wirklich gut
ausgestattet also da gibt es auch
inhalts räume anständiges essen man kann
auch mal ein bierchen trinken untersteht
eine tischtennisplatte
also das kann man wirklich gut aushalten
vierbettzimmern den wir da schlafen das
kann man wirklich machen und das freut
mich denn oft ist es ja so dass weißt du
ja auch als wissenschaftler dass
wissenschaftler viel weniger geld
kriegen als andere die irgendwo auf der
welt hinfahren aber hier sind sie so
ausgestattet dass sie jetzt
wirklich mal anständig forschung können
und hirn antarktis zu forschen das ist
unglaublich wichtig was sind dann zu den
großen themen die man an der antarktis
erforscht abgesehen davon was ich mir
gut vorstellen kann
das ist natürlich ums klima geht aber
das ist ja nicht das einzige thema oder
die station ja hinter mir die liegt
ungefähr so einsam wie eine station auf
dem mond eine raumstation auf dem mond
oder auf dem mars wäre man kann das ding
auch nicht länger verlassen weil man
erfriert also man hat eine isolierte
station in einer lebensfeindlichen
umwelt genau wie im weltraum
deshalb macht man ihr tests und zwei
tests habe ich mir schon angeguckt zum
einen steht ein kleines stück und die
richtung der sogenannte eden garten eden
container
das ist das deutsche institut für luft
und raumfahrt die versuchen da ohne
sonne und ohne erde frisches gemüse und
pflanzen zu ziehen mit dem man dann auch
auf mond oder aufmaß menschen versorgen
könnte und das ergebnis ist echt
erstaunlich so ein container ist glaube
ich nur so 16 18 quadratmeter groß aber
der wird genug gemüse tomaten und gurken
und also was ab um zehn leuten jeden tag
in frischen salat zu verpassen also das
ist die eine forschung wie kann man
unter solchen bedingungen überhaupt
frische lebensmittel ziehen und das
andere das hört sich am anfang
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch an
was macht eigentlich die isolation mit
dem kopf von menschen also im
antarktischen winter leben in dieser
riesen stationen nur neun menschen die
sind isoliert von der außenwelt man kann
sich ja nicht rausholen die müssen
alleine klarkommen
auch wenn man jemand krank wird müssen
alles alleine machen und das hat
natürlich auch auswirkungen auf die
psyche und jetzt hat eine neue studie
gezeigt isolation und die abwesenheit
von stimulanz hier ist ja immer alles
gleich hier wachsen keine bäume keine
farben keine leute alles immer nur weiß
isolation und eintönigkeit lässt das
hirn schrumpfen
es ist jetzt keine gute nachricht für
alle die ihr wohnen aber bisher ist das
nur ein messwert macht das heißt das
nicht automatisch dass man blöd wird das
heißt erstmal nur dass das hirn
wenn man hier ein winter verbringt
nachher ein bisschen kleiner ist als
vorher aber das bedeutet ja auch für
lange reisen durchs weltall da ist es
zwar nicht weiß aber da ist es dann
dunkel und möglicherweise auch immer
weniger stimulanzien wer weiß da falls
man außerirdische bei uns landen sollen
wer weiß wie lange die schon durch das
ewige nicht pflegen nicht stimuliert
sind und wer weiß wie kleinen deren
und dann ist ja sehr hoch interessant
also lediglich so genau auf dem auf dem
punkt ist problems aus der
raumfahrtforschung die aliens sind
wahrscheinlich durch wenn sie ja aber
ich meine da es geht ja dann es gibt ja
lebewesen in der antarktis hieß es dann
guckt man auch danach wie sich wie sich
leben dann unten entwickelt oder ist das
eher ein thema für für andere
forschungsstation ja das muss man in der
antarktis natürlich klar scheinen es
gibt an land wir sind ja hier auf der
antarktischen festland auf dem kontinent
gibt es kein leben das ganze leben
spielt sich im und am wasser haben
natürlich trifft man hier dann auf dem
eis haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt
tollen kaiserpinguine die hier in der
nähe eine große kolonie haben man sieht
wale die wir gefilmt haben man sieht
robben und alles leben spielt sich hier
mehr ab da ist das leben besonders prall
überdies sogar praller als in dem
regenwald oder irgendwann land allein
grill der ja hier gut gedeiht ist die
tierart mit der größten biomasse auf dem
ganzen planeten es gibt keine tierart
die 400 millionen tonnen auf die waage
bringen zuwider grillieren antarktis
aber an land lebt nichts und deshalb
kann man hier ja auch diese
weltraumforschung so gut machen also
egal wie lange man aus dem fenster guckt
da kommt kein reformer ist als einfach
aber es ist gar nicht also man ist es
wirklich alles absicht lose weiße weiße
landschaft das ist vielleicht auch ganz
schön eine retreat für führungskräfte
könnte das ja sein dass es da dass da
unten wirklich ist total still es hier
kann man sich mal zurückziehen aber ich
nehme an technologisch ist man gut
verbunden denn schon alleine dass es zu
dieser live schalte kommt ist ja ein
ausdruck dafür dass man offenbar
ziemlich gut technologisch von dort
unten fast vom vom südpol mit der ganzen
welt kommunizieren kann
und auch das ist eine gute übung für die
raumfahrt denn die logistik die dahinter
steht die menschen hier müssen sicher
nicht nur ernährungs mäßig sondern auch
die ganze energie das heizen alles muss
autark funktionieren und wenn was kaputt
geht müssen die neuen menschen die hier
alleine überwintern das auch alleine
zurecht kriegen also man lernt
unheimlich viel darüber wie man sein
team zusammenstellt welche technik wenig
belastungsfähig ist und wie man für
lange reisen in nicht irdische gegenden
eigentlich zum team ausrüsten muss all
das kann man hier wunderbar herausfinden
wenn ich das richtig erinnern
ist das schelfeis aber auch eines der
der verwundbarsten teile der antarktis
weil das momentan auch am stärksten
wegschmilzt und wie ist denn da die die
also ich nehme an das wird auch da
erforscht werden
es ist ein thema wie wie schnell die
situation die klimatische situation sich
am in der antarktis in den letzten
jahren oder jahrzehnten verändert hat
also auf der normalstation wird seit 40
jahren jeden tag das wetter gemessen und
wir wissen ja nach 30 jahren wetter hat
man zum ersten mal ein klima ergebnis
und das völlig überraschende ergebnis
ist hierbei der neumayer station ist es
nicht wärmer geworden dann habe ich mir
den glaziologen also den ice vorstand
gesprochen die es hier gibt und sie
sagen nein
in der antarktis selbst also hier auf
dem festland können wir bisher nicht
messen dass das eis geschmolzen ist
aber die antarktische halbinsel also man
muss sich die antarktis ist und dicken
weißen clubs vorstellen auf dem globus
und oben links also im nordwesten der
aktion kleiner zipfel nach oben das ist
leer und arktische halbinsel
und da ist der klimawandel schon voll
angekommen da schmilzt das eis da steigt
die temperatur und zwar erheblich aber
hier auf dem antarktischen festland hat
es sich tatsächlich bisher noch nicht
verändert und es ist allein deshalb
interessant weil wir dadurch verstehen
der klimawandel ist nicht einfach so man
macht irgendwo die heizung an und dann
wird es auf der ganzen erde gleichmäßig
wärmer sondern dass es überall
unterschiedlich es gibt ja sogar
einzelne regionen wo die eisflächen
wachsen wo es vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen kälter geworden ist das heißt
jetzt nicht dass es den klimawandel
nicht gibt das heißt nur erwirkt hier
anders und wir hoffen dass wir genug
zeit haben denn wenn das hier anfängt zu
schmelzen auf dem ich gerade sitze dann
wird es für die menschliche zivilisation
wirklich eng wir hoffen dass wir das
vorher verhindern können was ist denn so
die stimmung unter all denjenigen die
sich auf seiner station dann da unten
aufhalten und versuchen herauszufinden
wie die natur funktioniert die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
die sind erstaunlich sachlich wenn sie
dann in den themen arbeiten aber allen
ist klar dass wir historisches an so
kipp punkt stehen also wir hätten
wahrscheinlich noch die zeit das zu
retten alles sehen wir ja auch daran
dass die temperatur hier in der
antarktis noch weitgehend stabiles aber
man misst zum beispiel bei der luft der
messpunkt ist anderthalb kilometer von
hier
wir haben hier lernt arktis dieser
was die luft der welt deshalb kann man
veränderungen ganz fein messen wenn in
brasilien der regel wald brennt dann
kann man hier die rußpartikel in der
luft messen oder das projekt weltfrieden
das ist ja auch gibt mit infraschall
wird immer rein gehorcht in die
erdkruste und wenn irgendwo auf der welt
zum beispiel ein böser diktator eine
atombombe ausprobiert dann kann man das
mit diesem infraschall messen und es
gibt glaube ich 60 von diesen
infraschall messstationen rund um den
globus und die normale station ist damit
vernetzt man überwacht also sogar den
weltfrieden und bei biodiversität da
muss man natürlich ins meer gehen hier
das funktioniert im moment noch alles
ganz gut und die die die schönste art
das zu überwachen sind ungefähr acht
kilometer von hier gibt es eine grosse
kaiserpinguin kolonie und pinguine sind
eine sogenannte bio indikator art das
heißt wenn es im ökosystem schlecht geht
dann sieht man dass zuerst an den
pinguinen ihr seid ihr jetzt schon ein
paar tage doch da unten wie seid ihr
eigentlich dahin gekommen
es gibt inzwischen sogar flughäfen es
gibt sogar tourismus in der antarktis es
gibt ein paar private unternehmen dies
einmal möglichen sogar bis zum südpol zu
fliegen und da zu übernachten also wer
richtig viel geld zu verschwenden hat ja
könnte das machen aber ich fände es
nicht gut
also das ist ein kontinent der so
sensibel auf zu viele störungen reagiert
ich finde das sollte man der
wissenschaft überlassen das ist ja der
einzige kontinent der bisher eigentlich
nur der wissenschaft gehört die haben ja
nie menschen die siedelte wohl keiner
hier wird nur geforscht
es wäre eigentlich ganz gut wenn man
dabei bleiben würde wir sind erst nach
südafrika geflogen
und da mussten wir dann 45 tage rum
sitzen weil das wetter hier ein großes
thema ist und es war zu schlecht um
runter zu fliegen dann fliegt man auf
eine russische station auf die novo
station und wenn es gut läuft kann man
da mit zu kleinen flugzeugen die sozia
untendrunter montiert haben dann bis
hierher bis zur neumeier fliegen also
unsere anderes hat fünf tage gedauert
jetzt aber wie kalt ist es denn aktuell
bei euch das schwankt ganz extrem wir
sind mitten im antarktischen sommer die
jahreszeiten sind dann genau verdreht zu
uns zwei tage lang hatten wir ihnen ganz
schlimm sturm
das war wirklich so wenn man raus ging
hat der wind sofort umgeblasen also man
konnte gar nicht mehr stehen
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 100
stundenkilometern und dann mit dem
sogenannten white out verbunden weil der
winter so stark ist und es ja kein
windschutz gibt es ja eine große weiße
eben einfach nur wird so viel schnee
aufgewirbelt dass man die hand
buchstäblich vor augen nicht mehr sieht
und dann geht man von dieser riesen
station 3 meter weg und verirren sich
es ist also brandgefährlich für jeden
der beiden blätter rausgeht ok jetzt
haben wir noch eines wie weit seid ihr
denn von dem platz entfernt wo damals
scott festgestellt hat dass amundsen
schon vor ihm da war wie weit sind dass
vom südpol entfernt
die haben ja die sind ja damals gelandet
auf der antarktischen halbinsel und wir
sind noch ein paar hundert kilometer von
diesem magischen ort entfernt und
natürlich ist die geschichte von
amundsen scott auch ein teil den wir in
unserer terrex sendung erzählt das war
ja wirklich dramatisch und der sturm den
ich gerade erwähnt habe das ist genau
das was gott und seinen männern auf dem
rückweg passiert ist man kann wirklich
nicht mehr stehen man kann dann auch
kein zelt mehr aufbauen und das ist
absolut tödlich und so fühlen wir uns
also diesem schicksal des kommt
mannschaft ein bisschen verbunden weil
wir wirklich erlebt haben die
unglaublich brutal diesen taktischen
stürme sind also eher wer erzählt
geschichten um und über die antarktis um
und über diejenigen die versucht haben
diesem jahr kontinent mit all seinen
facetten zu entdecken und zu beleuchten
was mich natürlich jetzt aber du bist ja
im sommer klar du hast gar kein
nachthimmel
es wird niemals dunkel also auch immer
hell hier und wenn dann die mannschaft
im winter hier ist dann wird es ja dann
wird es ja niemals dunkel
er kann ich genau andersrum jetzt wird
es dunkel im winter ist also der
antarktische winter hier auf der
normalstation sind 63 tage
man sieht dann 63 tage lang die sonne
nicht und wir sehen jetzt werden unsere
gesamten aufenthalts den mond nicht
immer um haaresbreite hätte ich eben
gefragt wie ist denn der nachthimmel
müssen mir eingefallen ist ja klar du
bist ja es ist ja alles l bei der er
großartig
mein lieber ich wünsche euch alles gute
und kommt gut nach hause und wir sind
sehr gespannt auf die bilder die er
mitbringt auf die geschichten und bleibt
gesund und bis bald ja alles gute viel
lieber harald bis bald zurück in
deutschland